bonjour bonjour jean baptiste un bonjour
stéphane ton par contre on peut avoir
aujourd'hui la quarantaine variante
fouet le 5 c'est une grande variété
lacarrau cannes aujourd'hui on va suivre
pour nous aider deux grands spécialistes
la quarantaine sont annoncés drief voilà
donc la demande donc le mérite d'être
une espèce de tous d'accord mais qui
c'est vrai à des parties assez
convaincante contre la carotène et puis
un des spécialistes mondiaux actuels qui
est alexandre eev alors évidemment dans
les joints de karo kann très très connus
on a évidemment karpov confiant son
époque et
mais c'est vrai que de relief à
participer au développement de la
théorie moderne
tout comme je vois comme bas relief par
exemple donc on va suivre un peu comme
en anjou cette vente avec vous et 9,5
on va vous en parler alors que quatre
alors on y va on va voir si ces partis
au début avait que 4 1 la c6 c6 des 4es
cas des 5,5
donc pour ceux qui ont suivi la leçon
sur qualité set on a expliqué un peu le
principe de base de la halle à carreaux
can / m'enfin on y revient évidemment
calais c3 les noirs prennent en tout cas
pas ce qu'il y'a pas de quoi utile on
l'a vu dans l'autre leçon pour le
rappeler ici il n'y a pas de il n'y a
pas de coups utile pour mémoire vouloir
veulent construire un centre
d'information de pions sur les cases
blanches et après qui a lieu près prend
la 4 car ils veulent évidemment sortir
leur foute n'aurait qu'un blanc avant de
l'enfermer par le pion aux six ans donc
il va à l'arrêt un étau ici aussi c'est
6 pour empêcher toute velléité pour les
blancs de jouer des 5 avec avec les
décès cap des 5
ils ont verrouillé la casse des 5 voilà
mais avant d'enfermer le full pour faire
le sortir mais ils s'exposent se faisant
à une espèce de d'harcèlement voilà fou
qu'on va voir tout de suite c'est à dire
que le cavalier qui était bien placé en
4 comprend pas ce qui lui arrive il ya
un fou qui arrivait qu'ils attaquent ils
me demandent de reboucher alors allez y
au rouge
ça va pas se passer comme ça ils rouge
oui mais en attaquant fou en attaquant
fou voilà on lui prend des castes juste
retour des choses mais vous êtes obligé
de reboucher à son tour voilà à noter
que six fois plus de cases regardez nous
fout et prions h5 par le cavalier oui il
est pris au f5 par le cavalier il est
pris en tout cas toujours par le
cavalier qui s'appelle un câble et qui
domine le fou est évidemment des trois
essais de son prix donc il a inhalé un
yb est placé en justice mais il ne peut
pas bouger d'un iota s'appelle un
cavalier qui domine le fou mais ça
s'appelle aussi un fou qui domine cavani
c'est aussi ça mais en l'occurrence
conseil blanc qu'on l'initiative voilà
voilà c'est ça dépend qui a l'initiative
en fait ça dépend à qui c'est de jouer
voilà on est neuf
alors h4 alors h4 c'est pas un coup
c'est pas un coussin plein sache pas sûr
parce qu'on conseille souvent ne pas
jouer les phrases toutes les deux côtés
on joue pas des coudes sur les ailes
ouais pas des coups de pied et puis en
plus vraiment qu'on casse notre petit
rock
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire h4 déjà
on frappa petit - a priori on frappa
petit rock ça c'est clair préparer on va
plutôt préparer un grand roque alors il
ya une double idée et puis on harcèle le
fou sir combien de voir ce fou a pas de
gazon aux menaces des réalités seront
exacts et une triple idée alors
effectivement s'est enfermé le fou ça
c'est clair ils foutent menace sommaire
mais efficace c'est à dire si on joue à
chaque belle foule n'a pas vraiment le
15 pour pouvoir bouger après il réside
et positionnelle un peu plus profonde
je pense qu'à la fin cette leçon vous
comprendrez très bien quelles sont ses
idées plus profonde va commencer à en
parler c'est à dire les noirs ils ont en
gros deux possibilités pour battre le
roi de la bri et faire le petit rock ou
le grand roque
s'ils font le petit rock alors le curage
ils nous aident pour l'attack bien sûr
voilà c'est aussi simple que ça
si les noirs pour le grand roque on
comprend déjà un peu moins pourquoi est
ce qu'on a fait à 4 mais s'ils font
grand qu amy on va essayer d'attaquer
avec le trois pions fgh contre eux j'ai
h contre les quatre pions noirs qui sont
les pions e f g h et voilà et ses pions
ils vont nous servir à créer des
affaiblissements dans le camp noir sur
les droits
ce qu'on appelle une attaque de minorité
voilà donc on initie dès les débuts de
la libye cette ouverture du mont voir
ses traits positionnelle la can on
initie déjà 10
on anticipe une finale qui va avoir lieu
dans 15 20 coups où on va disons mettre
sous préservant une phalange de capian
qu'entre 3 donc ça veut dire une attaque
de minorité alors ça va devenir ça va
devenir parlante ravi c'est à dire que
sur h4 pour sauver le fou et il y en a
pas 36 coups volent ou agissent ainsi
voilà ah non on va pouvoir avec le kw/h
5 est envisageable aussi à oui mais là
ça serait embêtant on puisque s'inquiète
une cible est un peu faiblard quand même
après coup comme fou aux deux par
exemple 3000m encore plus encore plus
vicieux cavaliers 1e 2 comme le h3
melaky les venir en escale à part
attaque le fuji ce matin cloud pour tout
casser en réfection donc à certaines
vraiment très embêtant c'est pas
vraiment très embêtant donc à 4 le plus
logique ch chis faut sauver le fou alors
on sent le cavalier en f3 pour aller sur
la case d'avant-postes en ce sens qui
menacerait encore une fois qu'à
l'étranger si ce qui serait dramatique
pour l'histoire de pionniers là ça
serait horrible évidemment de prendre du
plomb f qui s'éloignerait du centre en
cassant totalement la structure de pions
en laissant le pion aux isolés isoler la
4 e 6 très faibles et des trous sur les
cases blanches théoriquement avant qu'on
joue cavalier 17-17 qui empêche tout
simplement très radicale hch sinclar là
maintenant ça devient un peu plus
parlant c'est à dire que mon fixe on
comprend mieux ce qu'on disait quand on
parlait des finales tout à l'heure des
finales typique de karo kann et bien ce
coup à chang c'est notre garantie pour
l'avenir voilà c'est notre assurance vie
d'antan les finales on bloque les pions
g h sur les cases noires et on fera
passer notre fou c'est un sur la grande
diagonale 1 h 8 alors attaqué le pion
c'est fou sans doute on va le développer
par des 2es en c3 une fois qu'on aura
bougé pion à ses 4 voix là et on va
contrôler cette grande diagonale ici
pour faire pression regardez sur ses
pions ici qui sont fixés alors le pion
âge voyez comme c'est malin et que ses
vues à l'eau à long terme un lot
évidemment à rentrer au centre du
pouvoir et vit jusque là il ya quand
même un certain nombre de
mais de façon quasiment systématique si
on joue correctement on va régler à
cette finale
ici on n'a pas gagné la partie parce
qu'on a une meilleure finale ici on a
joué à chaque gc pour l'avenir c'est
plus tard c'est l'investissement c'est
un investissement
peut-être que la personne qui nous
écoutent va se demander pourquoi est ce
que les pions seront fixés bien parce
que quand on a un pion qui rend g7 avec
noir avec aplomb 45 pour les blancs si
ce pion bush s'en va au moment où il
attaque et bien il est pris par le pion
h
et donc ça casse toute la structure de
pionsat casse le goût l'îlot de pions
solide comme c'est le cas maintenant
et donc ça devient plus facile pour les
manger mais évidemment sera pas chose
faite donc c'est des choses comme assez
profondes pour la finale donc faux
achète on y va il faut bouger le fou
alors vous êtes le fou est très actif
donc on va échanger se fout qu'il ya une
puissant maintenant placer en tête il
est tout à fait à l'abri comprend une
très belle diagonale comme en plus on a
envie de faire le grand roque
on n'a pas envie d'être constamment
toute la partie sous la menace nous faut
juste être super puissant tout à fait là
théorique considère que c'est bien de
les changer parce qu'il est quand même
très actifs cachés d'abord en contrôle
de la centrale la case de 4 et qui va
titiller leur enclos intéressant donc on
a on a tout intérêt à l'échangé se fout
il devenu quand même quelque chose de
puissant vide en plus un fou est loin
d'eux
sur la grande diagonale plus les
puissants appuis contre le 15 ouais donc
vous prenez trois d'en prendre trois et
maintenant aussi seller donc ça semble
quand même une bonne affaire en du côté
noir puisque on a mis les pieds ici
seront aussi sur case blanche on a bien
verrouillé la casse des 5
le fou on l'a échangé donc donc pas de
pas de faiblesse du côté noir une
ouverture quand même très solide
quand même un média pas de cautionner ça
c'est sûr c'est très très solide alors
le coup logique pour les blancs pour les
blancs mais non c'est effectivement le
coup pourquoi pas le kung fu et 4 c'est
bien fou au f4 c'est pas mal parce que
en fait on a envie bien souvent les
noirs veulent mettre la d'avancé voilà
il est bien avancé cet effort le grand
roque donc le couffo f4 a le mérite de
retarder le grand roque alors les noirs
peuvent choisir de jouer le coup à la 5e
choisir de faire grand parce que sur
demain 5 le meilleur coup c'est fou des
deux faut revenir avec le fond à la haye
et après ils reviennent en c7 et
finalement c'est comme si on avait joué
food et de douala perdre de temps c'est
comme s'il était fou des deux de ses
sept comme tu l'as dit voilà donc comme
ça on peut continuer là-dessus grand
roque grand roque cavaliers f6 kamel et
jf 3d comme c'est logique et que ça
coule de source
maintenant voilà alors le cabba les j3
pour l'instant il fait rien mais il a
fini son oeuvre mais dans son oeuvre
puisqu'il a chassé le fou donc il va
revenir en jeu pour s'échanger contre
une pièce active ou alain grand roque
pour les noirs c'est leur ôter le plan
alors la suite j'ai trois cc sg 3
intéressant toujours parce qu'on prend
lacazette 4 qui courent à la rockhal
intéressante puisque les noirs une fois
qu'ils auront joué pour des six plus
tard pourront éventuellement faire un
petit échec pénible voilà c'est toujours
bien de contrôler cette case s'empêcher
la dame d'y arriver les eaux faut aussi
d'y arriver là aussi et se prépare
peut-être notre foot et doux à venir 4
ne sais pas madonna sont menacés quatre
tournois live ce qui serait très bien
passé maintenant il ya plus d'un à cinq
échecs vous vous serez très bien placé
hors cadre
contrôlant nekkaz ici près du roi bolt
sur faux airs cadres qui ont mené une
incursion en d6 après plan national
ça serait vraiment très pénible donc
c'est pour pour sap
alors sur fouet cette ouais faut cette
voie là on peut se poser la question
qu'est ce qu'ils se portaient sur fond
f4f quatre points pour être joué c'est
pour ça oui ça pourrait mais c'est pour
ça que c'est encore un peu prématuré
puisque surnommait 5 alors damascène et
ben on a quand même un contre jeu sur le
pion à 2 voilà il ya un petit contre jeu
tout de suite il ya quand même un
contre-feu structurés dvas voilà donc
c'est pour ça qu'on veut pas le faire
tout de suite j'ai trois c'est bien en
général ça peut pas dire que ça crée une
menace
direct quand même c'est un bon point
quand même contre la cazelle cas
toujours important talent fou hausse est
de la part des noirs à la kabylie
problème si c'est un problème si ce
qu'elle prend un f6 attention la tour
maintenant rentrer en jeu autour des 8
qui crée un vis-à-vis sur la dame des 3
6 ans vis-à-vis à petit vis-à-vis donc
la menace des noirs c'est de jouer par
exemple ces 5 1 qui a goûté matic voilà
donc on s'enlève vis-à-vis on joue dames
deux coups thématiques dans la dalle à
carreaux caennais encore attention quand
même c'est à nous de ces cinq ce serait
aussi agi comme intel en plus on
contrôle un avant poste ou est-ce que le
pion à vii est un peu faible
les trois baby 3b un ouvrier ce qui
arrive ça est effectivement qui est fait
qu'il est aussi un thème de la carro
cannes donc dame de roye b 8
voilà pour éviter des échecs ultérieure
pourquoi pas ça me coûte toujours
prophylactique intéressant d'ailleurs
les blancs font de même avec roy b1 ou
l'attention parce que l'euro en bmx est
mis sur la diagonale dangereuse donc là
il va tout de suite à néant à 8 contre
vraiment il est quand même sur la
diagonale ici du fou qui pour l'instant
c'est pas trop grave parce qu'on peut
jouer sous les 6 voilà mais à terme ça
peut être très embêtant donc 3,8
voilà l'explication de ce courant 8 c4
c4
on joue le planton parler pour être le
fou en fait trois double intérêt du coup
ces quatre c1 ça contrôle des cinq qui
n'est plus une case pour le cavalier est
effectivement le deuxième idée c'est
qu'on va mettre le feu au c300 bloquer
le pion c'est sur la castine ce serait
dommage et en c3 regardez c'est la
grande idée qu'on dit c'est à l'heure
pourquoi en c3 et bien parce que par
transparence on va attaquer cette petite
chaîne de pions g6 j'essaie de ashes qui
pour l'instant est bien verrouillé par
le tournage 5
regardez comme c'est bien pensé cette c5
pouces et 3 puis on peut c'est certain
je pense pour epson vraiment fous ces
trois voilà avec avec toujours son atout
qu'il nous faut des plans on va pouvoir
tentés de voter riom c'est quoi la f4 g4
g5 on va commencer à attaquer sur les
droits et on n'hésitera pas à rentrer
dans la finale même la force est en fait
cette finale voilà ça peut être
intéressant effectivement de jouer cette
finale avec les planches des scènes très
faible voilà elias il ya parfois des
sacrifices à une heure qui sont elles
qui sont possibles sacrifices parce
qu'on va pouvoir jouer g4 g5 et sur
pions prendre mais on pourra envisager
pourquoi pas de sacrifier le fou sur le
budget 7 6 les protéger pour améliorer
les voilà pour libérer le qui ont h
je pense qu'on va parler dans cette
leçon on va en parler ne semble avoir
donc on va revenir alors sur flu f80 sur
fou et 4 voilà c'est bien sûr faux f4
donc c'est le coût pour empêcher gros
rock entre guillemets puisque on a vu
que les noirs pouvaient quand même le
faire et bien les noirs peuvent admettre
ça et se dire finalement qui vont faire
petit rock et jouer des requins poser la
foulée quatre échecs font mes quatre
échelles c3 c3 alors à quoi ça a servi
les noirs veulent faire petit rock et
les blancs grand roque
on n'est pas mécontent que le puits en
c2 s'avance un petit peu c'est un petit
détail c'est pas grand chose
voilà il faut hausse est en tout cas
c'était la case avoué pour ce fou oui
c'est souvent le genre de coups qui
effectivement semble un peu à l'eau
d'heure on a forcé 6 3 est ce que c'est
intéressant ou pas c'est souvent à ce
sont ce genre de petits détails qui
détermine une stratégie alors grand
roque cavaliers f6 qu'alléger civc leur
maintenance or malin 3 mios toujours le
con prophylactique est maintenant donc
c'est l'autre variante avec petit rock
donc avec petit rôti rock voilà donc ça
c'est la partie à d'andreev on continue
sur cette partie là alors on occupe tout
de suite maintenant la case
d'avant-postes février aux cinq
cavaliers au centre avec l'idée est
quand même il faut le dire un arrêt
d'enlever ce cavalier g3 pour pouvoir
libérer le plongé parce que là on a
avoué g4 g5 on a une offre pour attaquer
l'euro voilà on a une très très belle
percée
g4 g5 pour attaquer le petit rock et
ouvrir la colonne 05 voile à damas cinq
noms ni vainqueur ni prendre dessert les
prend 17 ans n'a pas peur pourquoi parce
que justement après car il prend 17
c'est rêver puisque cavaliers ne
contrôle plus la case la case ih 4 alain
tout de suite
ouais donc on va jouer cavalier 4 avec
l'idée de jouer g4 et de jouer g5 très
vite et là ça va chauffer ça va chauffer
ça va chauffer bien sûr les noirs ont
quand même un peu de possibilités sur
notre crocs
ils vont jouer avec des coups comme
c'est simple par exemple et après
qu'elle ait eu 4 quand même je pense que
les blancs dispose des meilleures
perspectives d'intel soit le petit rock
rue parce que le pion cesser ses deux
pions qui sont quand même déjà visé par
le cavalier en plus super agissait sont
vraiment une cible super pour un coup
comme g5 à coups de bélier comme je sais
qu'ils ne coûtent bélier en classique
pour enfoncer le rock adverse
alors après damas 5 après un cavalier de
5 par an au lieu de damas cinq y avait
une autre variante ce qui est une
réaction centrale plus fort peut-être
qui est plus intéressante qui n'est pas
le coup de relief dans la partie de
référence que l'un d'eux thing qui comme
très intéressante c5 c5
voilà parce qu on est en train de se
faire attaquer sur le petit rock ça va
pas tarder à arriver en tout cas donc on
prend les devants et on rentre attaque
au centre c'est toujours la brawn la fia
kallel réaction au centre toujours là
attaque à la réaction aux senteurs et
inversement attaques allaient leur
réaction à l'aise maintenant hâte à
calais la réaction sentons qu'on bloque
le centre pour la survie inversement
quand on veut développer le texte sur
une aile c'est mieux d'avoir le centre
fermé pour éviter la contre attaque au
centre donc d'un match 3 voilà pour
créer le vis à vis tour d un d'amd vite
donc la vraie exactement il ya une petit
vis-à-vis toujours désagréable tour
dames 1
donc là tout de suite d'ailleurs il ya
sans doute une menace évidente ses pions
prend ses cinq l'arrivée et après que
vont aider cette cloud et ses méthodes
mais j'ai eu un coup comme à 6 1 par
exemple la menace et puis on prend ces
cinq et ont gardé tout de suite la dame
noire
le cavalier 17 devant la dame noire donc
il peut pas bouger il faudrait prendre
le pion par exemple du fou et là tout de
suite un coup comme cavalier prendre
cavaliers cavani prend et
comme supplément d'âme prendre mais cet
essai terminé puisque le cavalier 17 et
plouay est quasiment foutu c'est presque
fini c'est postfinance hagarde courtois
7 qui tient à tora 7 qui est un peu
acrobatique avec un peu acrobatique mais
en tout cas on a pris un pion est un
avantage net on peut même rentrer en
finale puisque surtout à cet enfer
tranquille ça toute la cellule non mais
tu apprends bct pas que tu pourrais
signer un soyons la promesse était pas
le dire on est là on a sûrement des
conditions plus intéressantes pour
essayer de profiter du clonage comme
cavalier de 4 tout simplement voilà très
fort puisque sur dame ces sept on
pourrait faire par exemple ici tout
prendre cabanier on est entré taux
d'emprunt tour cavaliers profond voilà
ça c'est plus propre
donc c'est quelque chose de plus propre
un coup comme cavalier ou quatre avec
tout de suite
augmentation de la pression alors voilà
ah oui il vaut le vide donc le vis-à-vis
tour dames et désagréable dont jacques
diop dame f3 et bien on est noir vont
prendre des quatre forces et prend des
quatre plus tôt alors donc on prend en
et 4 mois là on reprend avec à tous
aller la tour c'est plus logique
puisqu'on va pas laisser le pion central
isolé on reprend il à tours on a cloué
le cavalier 17 c'est une bonne nouvelle
on menace évidemment de doubler les
tours donc ce qui serait pas une bonne
nouvelle
hélas les normands profitent qu elle va
lui prendre cinq à les prendre scène
puisque le cavalier in extremis réa tête
la dame f3 tout à fait on peut si on
prenait la dame des mythes ça serait
possible mais on aurait une mauvaise
finale puisqu'il y en aurait une
structure de mon cas c'est donc vraiment
très en jambes et on pourrait reprendre
du plongeon ici il y aurait deux pièces
les laines équivalence de pièces avec
avantage alors non mais on n'est pas
obligé de se presser vous propose tout
simplement on a quand même beaucoup de
pièces d'attac sur le petit rock ça
agréable cette tour en décapotable est
obligé de bouger alors huelva c'est que
la dame c7 lalalalalala pardon la casse
ces sept là qu'à ses centres il a fait
rêver elle est contrôlée de bout en bout
d'âme ses huit voix l'ademe c8 qui a un
coût possible en double ou en double et
pour tout racheter voilà et ce retour
des 8 c'est bien on peut encore le
libérer notre cavalier e 4 toujours
pareil on libère enfin ce cavalier g3
avec l'idée
pourquoi pas d'abord des changes est un
défenseur du rock et puis d'ouvrir la
possibilité là je veux quand même
signaler que les noirs ont bien joué
parce qu'ils ont joué tour des huit qui
d'un coup pour essayer de liquider les
pièces c'est en moyenne pièce musique
bah oui sinon aussi autour des 4 qui
restait là toute la partie ça allait
faire très mal sur le petit rock mêler
tous les problèmes sont encore résolu
puisque on peut maintenant avec les
blancs accepter cette finale j'écoute
j'apprends des quatre tours prend des
quatre ans des cas pour ton est calme
cavaliers prend à cadalen prend 24 dame
prend un cannois la b5 vaisselle pour
essayer de contre attaquer un petit peu
sur le sur le roc adverse alors quand je
lisais on peut accepter cette finale
parce que notre fou aux cinq top sur le
plonger cette s'est pas encore une
finale c'est encore finale potentiel
potentiel fort potentiel des taxis les
noirs veulent continuer à échanger ça ne
dérange pas en cause du fou aux cinq
étapes sur le plan g7
et comme tu le disait très justement
c'est pas une finale on a encore des
perspectives de textes écrits pour être
avec tours 2-3 avec lee détenues on va
jouer gk pourquoi pas f 4g 5 et
peut-être touché 3 derrière wayne tout à
fait ou bien même touche 3 tout de suite
on verra par la suite qui menace à tout
reproche et c'est tout simplement voilà
donc j'espère que vous avez bien compris
cet été qui est acheté un chien qui est
l'idée clé cette variante avec fleuve 5
voilà quand on a compris ça on a compris
qu'on avait un avantage en finale et un
petit plan qui aide pour la taxe sur le
petit rock city rock il y a alors on a
tout fait y compris sur la finale
alors on n'a pas vu forcément de
sacrifices angers7
je ne sais pas si on avait deux lignes
explicite le explicite là dessus
simplement on peut partir sa position en
parler oui c'est à dire si on est un
cavalier ballon d'une finale de pièces
mineurs avec un fou et 5 contres cavalli
ou 8 par exemple
peut-être peut-être un petit peu de
rouge à la casse de 8 pour essayer alors
peut-être peut-être le mieux c'est de
reprendre avec les grands et c'est ça
ouais avec red road accord donc c'est
cette partie là ouais c'est un loisir je
sais par exemple
voilà voilà voilà c'est typiquement la
voile avec cavaliers de 8 dans cette
partie wire regarder typique de la delà
de la position qu'on a analysées avec
les rock de couleurs opposées en a parlé
de cette finale on avait dit qu'on
allait qu'on allait encore bien peu
quand même
on imagine maintenant la position
s'entourer d'hommes alors il semble
qu'il y ait des échanges
voilà il ya plus de tours de pulls dame
à l'envoi du g5
alors imaginons les blancs masque alors
peut-être qu'on peut la f4 était joué
alors il faut que ce soit les noirs qui
joue là pour pour bien montrer
l'infirmerie oui d'accord donc on joue à
d'amendés 6 par exemple on joue
notamment des six en échange les dames
on va par exemple
ouais comme c'est pour offrir une
position un sens on prendra un vol a
bien sûr on va jouer
ok la tour ans et 7 c à tour en c5
larroy ans et 8 ans évite tout reprend
pour apprendre voilà voilà on a la
position
c'est simplement pas avoir la position
pour montrer l'idée générale comprenez
donc c'est très très fondamental de
comprendre ça ici cette structure l'aï
dominé par cette petite structure ici
donc il ya les trois pions dominent les
quatre de l'autre côté on a trois pions
qui domine les deux on va comprendre
pourquoi les trois pions dominé 4 et là
on voit bien que le fou tapez ici sur
les cases noires et que donc mais il
peut y avoir des idées de sacrifices
alors vas-y un cookie et j'ai sainte
alors un coup comme g5
voilà voilà parce que les radios puis on
prend j'ai cinq pions proche de 5 heures
actuellement que c'est un pion pas c'est
magnifique
inarrêtable voit pas l'arrêter parce que
lecavalier a pas les moyens d'aller
arrêter un pion comme ça ça le problème
c'est le fou domine le cavalier voilà
voilà donc ça c'est pas bon donc déjà il
faut que les noirs jouer autre chose
alors sur g5 disons s'ils bougent le roi
en c6 en disant tiens je vais laisser
comme ça mon pion à 17 mai mcdermott en
admettant qu'il aille en 17 aller et
bien tout simplement le sacrifice qui
tue et qu'il faut connaître
voilà où pranger s'était tu voulais
montrer que tu as à dire et vont devoir
montrer cette thématique fou pranger
c'est ce que font les noirs n'y a pas de
solution il faut prendre le fonds
chinois on a tout perdu
les blancs eux mêmes vont prendre à
chistera et sicav allait prendre mais
tout simplement le simple on a une âme
de plus puis au grand âge 6 et on ne
peut pas arrêter ce pion qui menace de
prendre le cavalier le roi ne peut pas
le protéger et si lecavalier bouge par
exemple au f5 on peut pas empêcher h7
est à chenilles dan
donc on va faire une dame voilà donc ça
c'est thématique c'est la finale à
connaître enfin le thème à connaître le
fou de me lecavalier fait pression sur
cette chaîne de pions qui a été dès le
début bloqué par le pion à cinq quand
même un chat un chat qui vint manoeuvre
à retenir pour cette leçon
voilà donc de quoi approfondir votre
connaissance de la quarantaine dans
cette variante officiel on va retrouver
certaines à 1,2417 aussi aussi leste
l'instruction de pions et la même
tournée pion est la même une ouverture
ça s'apprend en termes de structure
depuis longtemps qu'il faut retenir tous
ces petits
toutes ces petites ficelles alliant
voilà pour cette procédure sont merci à
jean baptiste merci stéphane à bientôt
au revoir